please welcome clyde peeling and his
animal chums
oh hi clyde
all right you know what i would love i
would love if this is not one of the
animals you brought it just
attacked you on the way in conan uh this
is a giant fruit battle or a flying fox
and it comes from india
and what he's doing right now is he's
slapping furiously
to try and escape the creepy man holding
onto his feet
that's correct that they hang from trees
upside down
roosting and when they go to take off
they actually flap like crazy
to get themselves in a horizontal
position and then they basically
drop and become airborne and when they
land it's a crash landing
so they don't really fly very well now
do these things uh
feed on the blood of humans uh
eventually become humans themselves and
walk the night
this is forever living as the undead is
that true fortunately
these are not vampire bats vampires are
much smaller than this
uh by the way evolution kind of takes
advantage of whatever's available and
this
is really the fingers and this hook is
the toe
right that he uses to catch and this is
it's sort of bat cape
that's spread around that's right uh
fascinating put your finger out here i'm
gonna
ah all right what do i do put him on
your head okay i'm not liking it i'm not
liking it i'm not liking it
ah yes
we could just hang him up if you'd like
i will lick the bat's head now
i don't get paid that much all right uh
what can i put the bat over here
you can see him on a rail there if you
want what is suddenly he's a hat
that i can just are you sure he'll he'll
cling on how do i do it yeah sure just
make there we go
he's lying he's going to make sure he's
okay i want to make sure that he doesn't
fall why don't you set up the next
animal while i hang him here okay or
help me out here or
just put him right there okay all right
he's telling just you see that he just
he just i will sue you
okay you know what sad
this bat really thinks it's getting a
beautiful view of new york at night
that's true just a crappy painting
whoa these are gliding frogs from china
straight right from your crotch to my
face whoa oh here's another one that's
okay oh i gotta get this one
okay i got it i got it i got this one
right here
okay good why am i better at handling
the animals than you clyde
just don't step on the one behind you i
want to i can put these anywhere
sure ah
okay oh
[Laughter]
that frog urinated all over my face
[Applause]
my face is covered in frog look at that
that's crazy
[Laughter]
[Applause]
kiss me clyde i'm sorry about that sorry
about that
i don't know the worst animal wrangler
i've ever seen
okay no frogs were hurt during the
filming of this segment all right
and this is where this is their natural
habitat a tupperware bin
actually these are uh tree frogs and
they have
okay there's one right there we gotta
move this along clyde
this is a very strange amphibian it's a
salamander
called a hellbender hellbender
yeah oh my god it's impossible to hang
on to can you pull him up where we can
get a shot of him here
oh okay these animals live in fast cold
streams in pennsylvania
appalachian
okay great all right i hate this
[Laughter]
[Applause]
something to dry myself on what
clyde's beard we got to keep moving
clyde what else we gotta get to so many
i love how we're learning nothing about
these animals either i don't know
what's this one it's squishy what's that
one it's pointy okay
here's one from australia and tasmania
oh and the audience on cue oh
what's that this is a wallaby which is a
small kangaroo-like animal
which is a marsupial of course and this
happens to be an albino
right something you wouldn't find
normally in the wild they probably
wouldn't survive
without a more natural coloration but a
number 50 sunblock
that thing is very beautiful looking
though and look at its toes its toes are
really cool
are those toes i don't even know the
correct term sure can the bat and the
wall
while we become friends we're going to
find out aren't we
i don't know we're going to find out
actually you're the worst animal
australian well we have we we don't have
too much time left so let's get one more
animal out because we really explored
every facet of the
wallaby oh my god and here's an animal
that's very rare
comes from uh asia this is called a
fishing cat
and it's an unusual cat because he likes
water he's actually adapted for catching
his food
in and around the water and he has
webbed feet for swimming
uh he's hissing he's getting high
he just realized who i was
everyone's become
[Applause]
conan uh you might want to let one of
the uh handlers grab that
yeah yeah let a professional get to it
clyde
i've seen what you can do that was
insane clyde what just who's this man
get away from that bat who the hell does
he even work for you who's that
there's somebody from your audience that
was insane
all right i have to change my pants uh
we're gonna take a little break feeling
everybody